so what are we you're an entirely  separate Consciousness from your body  your body has its own Consciousness that  is not you  and it does its own things without you  being able to see it it can change what  you see because it's between you and  reality it can change what you hear and  it can make you forget stuff it can make  you procrastinate and it runs an ancient  operating system that is not you that is  the platform that you run on you are the  Consciousness that sits inside it and  some of your Consciousness is in your  brain and some of your Consciousness is  non-local it's somewhere else so what is  this then what is it oh that doesn't  exist your body doesn't exist you're an  Eddie like in a river a little Whirlpool  there's constantly matter coming in it's  just a pattern in reality and that's all  your meat is